wow what an amazing way to end the
season of The Last of Us having played
the game I knew this ending would
absolutely obliterate everyone and I
think the execution of the climax worked
out perfectly Joel's rampaged through
the hospital to save Ellie while
simultaneously dooming the world is
narrative Brilliance this story beat is
amazing and Neil druckman for actually
making the scenario believable is
astounding because the fact that we
actually kind of sympathize with Joel
here is a really hard thing to do from a
story perspective given that he murdered
dozens of fireflies through the course
of the show we've really bonded to Joel
and Ellie and the entire experiment of
this Arc as if we'd accept what Joel
does here in order for us to accept this
we need to fully understand the
character and to be able to relate to
him having the sound slowly Fade Out and
primarily Drive the emotion of Joel's
headspace with the music was an
outstanding idea that helped with this
notion it really submerges you into
Joel's twisted and motivated perspective
what Joel is doing here is obviously not
right but what makes this so compelling
is that he's a character who's solely
motivated by what he cares about the
most he's someone who has been broken
since the death of Sarah and Ellie is
what fixed him this idea is expressed
and probably one of my favorite lines in
a script in a while where Joel and Ellie
say this so Time Heals all wounds I
guess
it wasn't time that did it
what a smart way to communicate this
without saying it outright having Joel
look at Ellie In This Moment visually
says that she is the one that cured his
depression and her realizing that is
peak writing to me and the crazy thing
is that I think this is a show-specific
moment from how integral this line is
for Joel's entire Arc I'm surprised it
didn't originate in the game unless if
they did say it at some point but it
wasn't in a cinematic so this moment
punctuate Souls Arc perfectly and I
think it's the best way to prepare the
audience for the upcoming massacre in
comparison to the game I think people
were more motivated to save Ali and to
kill all of these people because of how
much they've already killed in the game
it kind of becomes additional violence
and the people you kill here blend into
the already big body count you've been
accumulating for the show this is almost
the opposite because Joel and Ellie
haven't had to kill as many people so
Joel making the decision to kill the
fireflies is even bigger here it has
more dramatic weight because we haven't
been mowing people down in both the game
and in the show they are definitely
impactful segments but I think the show
executes it really well along with
having a lot of Great Moments to
communicate how far ganjol is like him
gunning down the unarmed Firefly and Tim
having to finish off someone with a
knife this particular moment feels like
a mirror to episode 4 where this drawn
out segment of this guy's death was
really haunting and difficult the fact
that Joel's unmoved by having to execute
this person and does it without
hesitation is a staggering contrast and
even the brief shot of showing Joel's
face after killing the doctor is kind of
terrifying Joel becomes a monster here
and it's okay to disagree with what he
is doing the show sets up both sides of
the coin as being immoral because even
Marlene is killing Ellie without her
approval obviously the correct thing to
do is to ask Ellie if she is willing to
sacrifice herself for the vaccine but
Marlene is equally doing a Bad Thing by
not giving her that choice which this is
meant by Joel's outrage so from a
character point of view everyone here
makes sense and it all clashes with one
of the best climaxes in video game and
even show history from here on out it
basically follows the game exactly which
makes sense because I think the ending
is spectacular through Ellie questioning
Joel and the circumstances in which they
left she knows that he is probably lying
to her so her giving him one final
chance to come clean at the end and puts
their entire Trust on the line I think
speaks volumes for what she knows deep
down so having Joel doubled down on the
LIE and compromise their trust is a
tragic ending despite it supposedly
being uplifting since Joel and Ellie are
back together again from here the
question remains as to how this will
impact their relationship going forward
and will Ellie ever find out the truth
of what really happened so the ending
was executed to a complete T in
comparison to the game and retained that
gut punch of an ending I'm happy nothing
was changed and despite people saying
that the ending was originally
controversial I think it has always been
an outstanding ending from here let's go
into some of the other strengths of the
episode in particular I love the cold
opening I kind of missed this tradition
that was set up by the first two
episodes and I'm glad it returned
because it has the opportunity to flesh
out the world a lot more having the
actors who played Ellie in the game
player mother is such a genius way to
pass on the torch and quite literally at
that but the fact that this scene offers
way more than just seeing Ellie's origin
is great we simultaneously learn how
Ellie gains her immunity through her mom
getting bits before she cut the
umbilical cord and seeing Marlene's
relationship with Ellie's mother in the
game Marlene's connection to Ellie was
pretty underdeveloped because her only
scene was her giving Ellie to Joel and
Tess along with the ending for the show
they develop her character a lot more
which was a good change because it makes
her eventual demise that much more
moving we understand the hurt and
conflict within her to kill Ellie for
the greater good and it offers an
interesting contrast between her and
Joel they both care for Ellie but since
she'll has been Shattered by Sarah it's
impossible for him to give her up
without fighting while Marlene is on the
opposite end of that Spectrum in which
he's a selfless person who wants to
serve the greater good at the obvious
expense of killing an innocent girl so
this cold open was actually really
important in the grand scheme of things
and shows how the TV show medium has an
easier time in telling stories given
that they cut to flashbacks without
interrupting the flow of gameplay then
the one scene that everyone has been
really excited for is the giraffe scene
this again was a perfect translation
from the game and captures the pure
Whimsical joy that comes from our
characters in this moment it essentially
operates as the Calm before the storm
and the pure Bliss that our characters
share here has Priceless value it also
acts as a good contrast to the last
episode in which Ellie brutally murders
David so having this moment kind of
brightens up her mood and she opens up
to Joel which I also liked how they made
Ellie barely speak in the beginning it
was a clever reversal of her character
and it immediately portrays the notion
that something is wrong with her she's
always been the one to constantly talk
and make jokes and it's even crazy how
Joel's the one making jokes now
considering his starting points along
with him opening up more about Sarah
everything up until this point was
basically pulled from the game but the
addition in which Joel tried to kill
himself adds another vulnerable later on
to Joel that increases his overall value
in my eyes the show has really made Joel
to have fractured and hurt individual in
the reveal of his suicide attempt adds
another brilliant final Lair especially
since he lied about it earlier so the
Callback here has even more meaning
going into one aspect about the episode
that has been getting criticized the
most is the pacing the common complaint
is that the episode was way too fast and
they should have slowed down and for
once I kind of agree with this sentiment
I do think the pacing was pretty solid
and included no filler at all it was
very optimal in a way however since this
is the finale I think it should have
been longer Joel and Ellie's current
journey into the city feels kind of
weird because it essentially has no
conflict this is actually the one time
where I think the game did a better job
in its execution of events in the game
they had to maneuver through a tunnel of
infected and eventually they got into an
area that has a rip current going
through one of the tunnels and Joel and
Ellie gets swept away when they emerge
Joel is trying to resuscitate Ellie and
in the process the fireflies capture
them to me this leaves A better ending
for Joel because it acts as more of an
emotional Cliffhanger for him Ellie was
on the precipice of death and suddenly
he can't see her again it creates a
sense of emotional shock for Joel
because the last thing going through his
mind was Ellie being close to death so
the first thing he wants to do upon
waking up is see her again and to
reassure his biggest worry that she
isn't dead this creates more of an
urgency to see Ellie because this is his
last memory of her instead of a happy
one in which they are sharing puns then
Marlene denying Joel to see her again
stings that much more because of the way
things ended so if they went from the
pun scene into a zombie scene that then
gets interrupted by the fireflies I
think it would have flowed much better
now I don't think this pacing issue
compromises the climax in the show by
any means but I think it is a minor
downgrade from the game along with the
fact that it would have been nice to see
a bit more zombies I did just say my
last video that it's not a big deal to
not include that many zombies within the
show but this is the one time where they
would be appropriate it would have given
Joel and Ellie one final obstacle to
overcome together before the ending
because when you think about it the last
time they really cooperated was back in
episode 5. so seeing them work together
as a team to show their efficiency and
growth would have been great to see I
think this would perfectly time the
infected threats and would have easily
combated the notion of there being a
lack of them there is an infected
appearance in the beginning of the
episode but since Joel and Ellie are in
a city again it would make sense to have
an encounter so while this isn't a major
flaw I'm surprised by the rare instance
in which the game is better than the
chauffeur ones this is a pretty straight
adaptation since there aren't a lot of
original moments here in the show and
this is a time in which they should have
brought more over from the game overall
though I think episode 9 is a slam dunk
in its execution and this marks one of
the best video game to TV show slash
movie adaptations sitting right next to
Arcane in terms of quality I am really
excited to see how they handle the last
of us too so far they've announced that
Bella Ramsay will remain as Ellie which
I think is a great choice it was kind of
in question because of the second game
doing a time Jump but she's 19 so she
can definitely play a slightly more
mature version of the character then
they're also going to do two seasons of
The Last of Us too considering that the
game is huge and is like double the
length of the first game so yeah thank
you for joining me on this series and
I'll put a playlist of each one of my
episodic reviews in the end screen have
a great day and let me know what you
thought about episode 9 of The Last of
Us
foreign